I like to joke with people that I have
made a paper airplane when you think of
a paper airplane you probably think of
something like this but for one designer
a paper airplane is something completely
different
and a lot more detailed and of course
they're not people
I'm sure think I'm totally crazy and
then when I actually show them photos
they often are pretty shocked and they
probably think I'm crazy in a different
way which you know might be valid for
nearly a decade on-and-off-again Luka I
Akoni Stewart has been painstakingly
designing and building this 160th scale
model of a Boeing triple7 it's a project
that's really hard to explain in in
words and so I often avoid doing that I
just kind of skip to pictures because
that's really the only way you can
convey this sense of detail and just the
kind of insanity of it all it even blows
my own mind I don't really know I've
done a lot of it this is no
off-the-shelf model he uses a bare
minimum of tools and materials it's you
know manila folder glue exacto blade
straight edges it's a pretty simple set
of materials that I use and it's small
about using those two to make all
different kinds of things and that's
kind of the challenge and the fun in it
I have cut myself doing this project
definitely sliced the very tip of my
finger off just the skin it all began as
a school assignment it started on a much
smaller scale in terms of the detail
there are still parts of it that are
original but I increased the complexity
over time I just found my skills
increasing and so I wanted to add more
detail and I've torn it apart many times
to add more stuff or to make it more
accurate so detailed that there are tiny
lamps made of strands of paper above the
first-class seats and moving wing flaps
engine parts and landing gear that
actually retract created both sides here
and I mounted them in this like little
test
that replicates the main structural
elements that they're connected to so
this would be like the cabin floor would
be this way and then the wings would be
kind of this way they have all the kind
of steering function so it was actually
kind of shocked that it all worked out
given how small the scale is yeah this
is completely made out of paper the the
tires are completely solid core insides
that they can actually support a fair
amount of weight this is the nose
landing gear which is a lot less complex
but even at the time that was another
piece so it was kind of like wow you
know I can't believe this
this has worked out as well so it just
kind of retracts like that it's a pretty
simple concept but you know getting it
to work in paper can be a challenge
there are two types of manila folder I
use there's a thinner kind that's like
the regular folder you might you know
encounter in the wild and then there is
a thicker kind that's more of a divider
though I use those for structural
elements like in the wings it needs to
be much more kind of load-bearing making
these parts can take weeks or even
months luca designs the pieces prints
them cuts them out by hand and then
painstakingly glues them together there
is a fair amount of concentration that
that i have to have when i'm putting
this stuff together but once i kind of
get the hang of it i know what i'm doing
this is very much a unique project in
that i've had to research everything and
drop my own plans and that's what i
think a lot of people don't realize I
think I'm either working off a kid which
is understandable but that's really not
the case and I've had to come up with
all of my own plans and obviously even
if you had a kit it wouldn't really
translate or lend itself to this type of
material you know I have to translate
what they make into something that I can
build and that will work in paper and
there's a huge difference in how you
know something will look the same on my
model but the way it actually works is
completely different because I'm taking
into account how paper responds not
having plans means that sometimes
hundreds of hours of work end up
scrapped so this I like to jokingly call
the plane crash because
you know it's like so these are all
sections that I've kind of ripped out
over the years you can see this is like
the cabin side wall kind of looks like
again like what you might see in a plane
crash just totally shredded parts of the
fuselage so why would anyone spend this
kind of time on a project like this I've
mainly done this project because I
really enjoy the sense of calm and
meditation that it brings when I can
really get into the building process the
most satisfying thing is to look at
pictures and know the actual plane and
transform that into your own plans and
then see it actually come together in
paper that's probably the most rewarding
feeling and it's kind of exhilarating
when you get to the end and you really
see a component coming to life it's like
a really exciting sense of achievement
and so that's kind of what keeps me
going
sections of the cabin actually open up
to reveal the interior so that's first
and business class and this is business
and economy I haven't been able to fully
replicate all the detail or rather
haven't wanted to the overhead bins
don't open the seats don't actually
recline I think people often think they
do but they don't unfortunately thanks
to some press and luca's popular YouTube
channel the plane model has taken him to
some unexpected places even to the
actual Boeing assembly line and so I
actually got to see their whole
production facility and actually got
really up close to these planes and that
was an amazing experience their assembly
line is really a feat of engineering
obviously it's and the sense of scale is
just otherworldly and it's landed in
pain work making this advertisement
about two years ago I was contacted by
Singapore Airlines and I was lucky
enough to work on a project with them an
ad campaign for social media and so I
actually got to build this plane behind
me the a380 2/3 was their flagship and
after thousands of hours of toiling over
the paper version a few years ago he
finally flew on the jet his model
replicates a Boeing triple7 300gr
I really was glad that I was finally
able to and it kind of unfortunate that
it took me so long but it was it was
cool just to see the actual thing all
that time looking out the window got him
ready for the last challenge so yes the
plane does not yet have wings I'm kind
of in the midst of designing them and
I've broken them down into sections and
I've been slowly creating each different
subsystem if you will but yeah it's it's
a notable omission thus far and that's
kind of the last it's like the last
thing I have to do which is in fact a
multi-year ordeal I'm not sure why I'm
so interested in airplanes when I was
little it was trained I think it's hard
not to be amazed by the fact that these
huge pieces of you know metal and now
plastic can take off into the air and
that they're they're so advanced and
complex the testament to human ingenuity
[Music]